I want to ask you guys uh uh DAV and
chrisis I want to ask there's a lot of
there's a sort of a tradition of a band
has the first you know I know that uh U
never mind it's not your first record
but this big success you tour off that
success and then they have to go right
into the studio and they're
exhausted you guys had had some downtime
and the impression I get from everything
I've read and everyone I've talk to is
that you came into the inudo
experience ready to go with a real sense
of purpose and playing really
well is that does that feel right to
Accurate description yeah I think
so well we we we the first song we did
was serve the servants and then we had
met Steve and he set up and then I
remember Steve just standing by the that
big stter tape machine that and you know
just he's hits record and he's got his
arms crossed he's watching us and we
knocked the song out in one take we're
like oh that was the keeper literally
the first thing recorded in the session
is the first song on the album as
recorded yeah I think uh never mind I
think it was 2 months maybe to make and
then Udo is never mind was like 12 days
or 14 days was it 14 days I thought it
was it was really quick really the
recording of it yeah the recording of it
but then it's the mix the mixing and
everything that I mean I think Soup To
Nuts Udo is two and a half weeks three
weeks less we we I mean if we had if we
had been a little bit more efficient we
could have been out the door in 12 days
but I I think we were done in 14 for
sure you here's the thing so um because
we were looking for that kind of uh
performance and we were looking for that
kind of recording and most of the takes
were maybe one or two takes or something
um we were done with the drums and I
think the basic tracks in what three
days or three or four days three or four
days so that left
me uh with a good week of sitting around
doing nothing in that
house like The Shining watching those
David atenor videotapes like things like
that wait why you watching David atenor
nothing else to do yeah this is before
uh streaming this is a different time oh
I would do the fireplace I would start
fires remember and I would do the
fireplace very primordial primordial
primordial activity is a a man tending
the fire it was very shiny it was very
shining yeah okay you mentioned it so I
can bring it up you say tending fires
there was also some Pyromania uh
happening during the making of In in
utero and I don't know if this was it in
this was something that you guys picked
up from these guys would play with
lighter fluid yeah let's talk about
that clean there was a cleaning solvent
that was used in the studio to clean the
tape heads and clean clean equipment and
stuff it's a very pure alcohol that
burns off so you can like you can put it
on your hand and set your hand on fire
like oh look I'm you know I'm the Human
Torch blah blah blah whatever and so
some here I've brought some in we're
going to all douse ourselves with it and
you know you get bored with setting
regular things on fire and then you
start setting other people on fire and
stuff you know what what what kind of
things are you setting on fire did you
my ass we did that on I think you lit a
cigar off of my ass yeah that was uh
while that was on fire was there any how
long is your ass on fire for what's the
amount of time uh well long enough for
long enough for for Chris to light a
cigar so that's I'm thinking at least 10
seconds for someone to take a picture
yeah okay did you ever smell anything
cooking yeah just our hot tracks um no I
think that uh yeah I mean you know we're
out in the middle of nowhere with
nothing to do no things thing you light
things on fire uh there were also prank
phone calls oh cuz Steve had this
realistic like remember radio shock and
it was a it was a microphone like you
can stick on a phone the microphone part
of a phone the receiver the receiver
part you record you still have it I
might have you have some of these
recordings you can record off the phone
like on a cassette right yeah okay uh
I've done some research and like Nixon
you should have gotten rid of these
tapes uh you guys pranked Jean Simmons
yeah I believe it one of Kiss Fame
that's my favorite one who Des who
deserves pranking by the way favorite
one I don't know if you've ever spoken
to jeene Simmons he yes I have I love
the Melvin that was my favorite he says
what I love the
Melvin he does he does he sounds just
like Jackie Mason yeah he uh he was on
my show once and all he did was sell
merchandise and I kept trying to get him
to tell interesting stories and he'd say
we'll get to that and but first and then
he'd go in and he'd say the kiss coffin
and he had a kiss coffin that he was
selling absolutely true uh the thing
that's weird about the
my the I I pretended to be Kurt calling
Jean Simmons back he Jean Simmons had
reached out to Kur Jean Simmons had
called their management because there
was a kiss tribute album being put
together and Nirvana the biggest band in
the world were friends with the Melvin
and the Melvin did a Kiss cover and he
assumed that Nirvana would want to do a
Kiss cover to be on Jean Simmons cannot
fathom that anyone on Earth is not a
massive kiss fan right
he's I'm going to say this a healthy ego
and Jean if you're listening this is a
good thing to have when I was like 12
years old to like maybe 14 I was huge in
a kiss yeah yeah and Jean was my
favorite yeah and Nana had recorded a
kiss oh God I was a disaster what did
you record we were drunk do you love me
uh-huh we were drunk okay well a few
drinks are needed to record a Chris Kiss
song Sometimes occas so the word comes
down that Jean Simmons is desperate to
get Nirvana on this album and Kurt is
and and it's the the the appeal comes
from management like through directed
through management like we got this call
from Jean Simmons he's really hot to
have you guys on this album do you want
to call him back and Kurt is like I
don't want to talk to Jean
Simmons and I said I'll do it you know
so I called him I called them called him
back and I pretended to be Kurt and I I
def like like parried the whole thing
away by saying that I wasn't making all
the decisions because had a reliability
problem so you're and are you talking
directly to Jean yeah as Kurt and Jean
thinks he's talking to Kurt yeah and
Kurt is sitting right next to me
listening to me doing impression of him
you do a really good Kurt by the way can
we hear just a second of you talking to
jeene sim I can just see Kurt giggling
yeah he was choking it back can I hear
you do you know do do you know the
wipers that's a good I I really love the
wipers do you know the wipers and then
Jean Simmons comes back with I don't
know the
wipers I know the M know I don't know
the wipers uh you call I love this one
you call Evan dando no even better Evan
D there was someone in Evan dando's tour
party who was a friend of Nirvana and
had the phone number for the studio and
called from a hotel in Australia a
direct call from a hotel in Australia
probably the most expensive
phone call that you could make right
right build to the to the room so Evan
danzo's Evan D's like footing the bill
for the most expensive direct call on
Earth and what we did was
we somehow we convinced that guy found
Evan and convinced him that Madonna's
personal assistant had found had tracked
him down yes at the hotel in Australia
and wanted to talk to him that's it
that's the whole that's the whole
context so Evan Doo thinks he's on hold
waiting for Madonna right and every few
minutes I would get back on the
phone and say she asked me to place the
call she's still busy can you can you
wait a little bit longer and I had some
absurd accent that I thought Madonna's
assistant would have you know and and
now Madonna has and then he's just like
yeah of course yeah sure I'll wait yeah
of course and
so literal silence for minutes on end on
this and then the sound of him
exasperatedly like telling everyone
around him like I'm on the I'm on hold
for Madonna you
know and the whole time and he's paying
for the whole thing sure because it was
actually the call actually start
$700,000 prank phone call yeah yeah that
one was that one was pretty funny and
then Australian dollars Eddie veter I
think was there a prank called Eddie
veter at some point yeah yeah and I
don't remember why that one that was me
as well I don't remember why we did that
one cuz I don't there was no you guys
weren't like fighting or feuding with no
no no so um I do remember getting him on
the phone and telling him I pretended to
be Tony visanti record producer that
you're by the way you're supposed to be
the adult in the room I remember that
you know you're the guy that's supposed
to be you're in charge and you're
lighting you're lighting artists on fire
and uh and and and prank calling
people's like I'm producing David Bowie
or something I remember that I can't
remember what it was I can't remember
the context but I was like yeah I'm uh
I'm here with the black crows or
something I had some band that
I claimed that I was with and then I and
and they were playing me your record and
I I want to get you in the studio with a
real band guys who can really
play that's pretty good did he get mad I
or no well you have these you going to
you got to put these out at some yeah I
don't I don't I genuinely don't remember
the the banter but I do remember I think
I thought handled it pretty deftly I
don't I think he acquitted himself well
like talking on the phone to Tony
Visconti record producer who wanted to
fire his band do you uh you say at one
point you
say he goes where where are you and you
said uh I'm in I'm in
Manitoba and then he said he said do you
know do you know where that is and
there's this long pause he goes
no